LAURENCE MORONEY: Did you
know that 86% of users
don't like creating and
remembering new passwords
to interact with you?
I'm surprised the
number's that low.
I'd have figured it was 100%.
Not only that, but 54% of
users will quit altogether
if you ask them
to fill out a form
to create a new account
just to sign into your app.
All that time and effort
you've spent attracting them
to your app, and more
than half of them
would walk away before
they even start using it.
And it gets even worse.
You've gotten them to the
front door of your app.
They've actually signed up for
a new username and password.
And when they come
back, of course,
they can't remember their
username or password.
Guess what?
A whopping 92% of
them will walk away
when this happens
instead of going
through the reset process.
I'm Laurence Moroney.
And I'm here today to talk
about sign-in with Google,
allowing your users to
simply use what they know,
trusting that their
login is secure.
So you're thinking,
this is all very good.
But you've implemented
sign-in already.
You might even have implemented
sign-in using Google.
Either way, I've got
great news for you.
The UX has improved greatly.
Let me step you through it.
But first, let me show you
what it used to be like.
There were a lot of
steps, a lot of steps.
And the user experience
just wasn't the greatest.
We did make some
mistakes in our design.
Sorry about that.
Well, here's the good news.
That's a thing of the past.
With the new APIs that first
shipped in Google Play services
8.3, we've greatly
streamlined it.
First, you pick that you
want to sign in with Google.
Note the nifty new
Alphabet branding.
We'll show more of
that in a second.
Then, your users are
asked to pick the account.
And then, they're in your app.
So easy it's not even worth
shooting a video about it,
right?
But I've started,
so I'll finish.
Earlier, I spoke about
the new graphics.
There's a set of branding
guidelines about them
at this URL.
Here you can find
the standard button
that I've shown in both
light and dark themes.
You can download graphics
for it in disabled, focus,
normal, and pressed modes.
And the basic elements are there
so that you can customize it
in all kinds of dpi,
including hdpi, ldpi,
all the way up to xxxhdpi.
And don't worry.
This triple x is safe for work.
And that's it for this Dev Byte.
Stay tuned to the Android
Developers channel on YouTube
for more, including how you can
write all the code to achieve
this kind of sign-in
and allowing your users
to share their identity
with your server.
I'm Laurence Moroney.
And you're going to
go build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]